I've been in business for 14 years. I
recently did a $106,000 book launch in a
weekend. And our portfolio of companies
at acquisition.com does over $250
million in aggregate revenue. And a
portion of that is brick-and-mortar
chains that we own. And so, in this
video, I'm answering your questions
about how to scale specifically a
brick-and-mortar HVAC business. And for
all of those questions, I try to do my
very best to make the solutions as
tactical as humanly possible so that you
watching from home can actually use this
stuff. Enjoy.
>> My name is Thomas. I sell roofing and
exterior remodeling. We do uh close to 6
million this year. I'd like to be at 100
million. What's stopping me, and I'll
I'll be a little bit vulnerable, I would
say it's comfort, distractions, and
fear.
>> And food?
>> Fear.
>> Oh, sorry. I was like
>> [laughter]
>> All right, good to know. You know.
>> Not food. No.
>> Sometimes I feel that way, too.
Uh
>> So, the the comfort is I have built the
business, I've replaced myself in every
aspect. I can work two to three hours a
week and it'll run fine.
>> Okay.
>> Um fear, I would say the fear of losing
family time.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh the work-life balance.
>> Sure.
>> And the distractions are uh my other
I've got another business, junk removal
business. Um
I've got real estate, I've got
uh
just all kinds of little things.
>> you think you should do that you're not
doing that you want me to tell you to
do?
>> So So, I know I need to go all in again.
>> Okay.
>> And And I did that the first five years
that I that I was in business. And it
worked out great.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Um went through COVID. Um I got, you
know, kept the business going really
well.
>> Mhm.
>> And I worked myself out of a job.
Got comfortable.
>> Okay.
>> So, I don't know what I'm looking for
you to tell me to do.
>> Well, I'll say I'll say this
differently. Um
I think regrets come when we imagine
the upside that we don't have without
taking into account the cost that we
didn't suffer.
And so, I think we regret um when we
imagine the upside
that we didn't get without also
considering the downside that we didn't
suffer
to get it.
Um and so I think that's where a lot of
regret comes from cuz it's not it's not
real. So it's like maybe there's some
girl that got away or some business
opportunity that got away and we just
imagine
this amazing thing but not the trade-off
that we would have to do in order to get
it. We just imagine the upside without
downside. And so I would say a couple
things. So one is
um
I think that there are there are
trade-offs that we always have to make
and I don't I don't think they're right
or wrong. I think they're just they're
preference. There's no right answer to
how much work-life balance you want to
have. It's right for you.
And so said differently, if I like
cookies
and I'm good with that and I also want a
six-pack, I just prefer cookies to a
six-pack.
It's just that's the trade and I think
the the dis- dissatisfaction comes from
wanting both.
>> Right.
>> Right. And so either
want less
or trade more.
And I think that's really what it comes
down to in terms of like is there a path
where I can work on more than I
currently am
um to go from six to 100? There probably
is. It depends on how much you're
willing to pay other people. And so you
might have to take a short-term hit in
terms of profitability
uh to bring in the level of talent that
you want to expand the business on your
behalf to where you want it to go.
And so as long as you were the type of
person character-wise that they would
want to follow and believe in your
vision and you can make your vision big
enough that they think that their
aspirations can fit within it. You can
get that type of person.
But like it's it's 100% like you're
you're graduating right now into the who
game.
>> Yeah.
>> Um but there's levels of whos. You know,
like I remember
um the first time I hired a $50,000 a
year employee and I was like this is the
[__] This is what I'm talking about.
You know what I mean? Like I went from
minimum wage, you know, labor to 50. I
was like this they're they can read,
they can write. Like let's let's go. You
know what I mean?
Uh and then I I hired my first
six-figure employee and I was like oh
what was I talking about? Like this is
what's going on. And then I have my
first 250, first 500, first million,
first multi-million dollar per year
employee. Um
and it's just levels. And so um Sheran,
who's our president, said this to me
years ago, but I always remember he said
the best the best talent's always in the
future.
So whatever we have today, the best
people are always ahead of you, not
behind you.
And so um I think for you, if we if you
really do want to accomplish it without
making the trade, you will make a trade
cuz if you change nothing, nothing will
change, right? So we have to change some
some component of your life. And so the
question is which thing do you value the
least?
Do you value having more profit or more
time with your family? In the short
term. In the long term you can make it
up. You won't make up family time in the
long term. You can't make the profit up
in the long term.
>> Right.
>> So if you're willing to give up
short-term profit, you can bring in
high-level talent, and then they can
lead the growth. In terms of the uh the
fear stuff, I mean I would just say like
just ho- hold the line.
If you don't You're like, "I'm afraid of
losing time with the family." It's like
just don't. Like I you know. And then in
terms of the real estate thing, I see
real estate cuz I know about real estate
entrepreneurs. I've a ton of real
estate. Um I don't like as long as
you're not like actively running it, um
like that's why I'm a big fan of like
REITs and funds
uh because you have if you have you know
good partners and that stuff, um
they can just run it. You can make
better than the market. And then but
it's not it doesn't change anything
about what I do. Like me putting in the
S&P or me buying another big building
changes nothing about my life. And so
it's not a distraction unless you're
like, "You know, if we could add a
gazebo. And what if we added a different
roof cuz I'm a roofer? And what if I
combined what I'm really You're like,
"Dude, stop. Just like let the real
estate be the real estate, let the
business be the business, and just keep
them apart." As long as you're good
there cuz I think it's a distraction.
Um
actually let me double-checking that
real quick, which is when you say to
your the distraction thing that you're
afraid of, why are you afraid of that?
>> I'm not afraid of it.
>> Okay. I'm just I've got ADHD and I
I collect gold and silver. I buy houses.
I buy buildings, I buy I mean it's just
>> Yeah.
>> a little bit of the red dress.
>> Well, as long as it doesn't change
anything about what you do, I don't
care. But if it's like now I check this
stuff all the time and it like eats up
my days, then yeah, I would say that's a
problem.
Um
and it's only a problem if you decide
it's a problem. Like you might just like
that stuff. It's just like I sacrifice
my goals cuz I enjoy this ADD.
You know what I mean? Like the cost of
the big thing is the new stuff that you
have to give up to keep it going.
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you. I felt like I needed some
amens.
>> [laughter]
>> It's like a good meal, right? Yeah.
I appreciate it.
Um but yeah, that's like the cost of the
big thing is all the new stuff you have
to give up that you don't get to pursue.
All the exciting things that you will no
longer participate in because you want
to do one thing big.
>> Okay.
>> And I think um for me personally, I had
this moment um I think a while ago, but
like I had this realization of how long
it takes to get good at anything.
And then I thought about oh, I only have
like 30 or 40 more productive years
>> [laughter]
>> at most. And so I'm like I've got like
four five big seasons in me left.
>> Yeah.
>> And so that's it. And so I don't have
like unlimited shots on goal. I've got
four five big runs in me.
So.
Hopefully that helps.
>> Appreciate that answer cuz I thought you
were going to say sell everything and
>> I mean, they're investments. I mean I'm
not going to say sell your investments.
I would say
keep passive stuff passive. Don't make
it active. It's like incurring cost. Cuz
if you're going to make it active, then
make active money.
>> Yeah.
>> If you're like I want I want to take my
passive money and then it make it cost
me more time to get 5% better returns,
it's like you're going to get way better
returns in your active income than your
passive.
And just I would just keep active
active, keep passive passive.
>> Thank you.
>> Appreciate you.
>> My name is Corey. I'm an electrical
contractor. I do 1.6 million a year. I
probably keep about 650 of that. I'd
like to be about five is kind of what I
can see right now.
>> All right.
>> My biggest constraint is myself plus
hiring quality candidates.
>> So, you can handle the volume you have
right now. Or so, you can't handle the
volume you have. You could get more
business, but you can't handle it.
>> I can handle it when the whole crew's
here.
>> Okay.
>> And then, as soon as one guy's gone, I'm
back in the van.
>> Yeah, so you need more people.
>> More people.
>> Yeah.
>> I got it.
>> So, we have to think about like so, this
is probably a multi-step thing just for
everybody like as we're falling through
this is like if we have if you have
enough business, which it sounds like
you do, that's not the constraint, then
it probably means we need to bump price.
And we bump price so that we can have
the cash flow, so that we can hire the
extra person, so that you have
redundancy in the team.
Right? Like if Alex had to hop in if if
Tim's sick, that's not going to work,
right? We have to have two or three
backups for any person who's here so
that I can keep doing my job, right? And
so, but I can only do that if I have the
cash flow to sustain
multiple teams, right? And so, this is
where sometimes it's like a multi-step
solution. So, it's like we have to fix
the pricing component. And it's like,
okay, well, I feel weird charging more
because other people in my market charge
even less than I do, and I'm a little
bit above the market, right? So, then we
have to think about the offer. It's
like, okay, so the offer might be the
issue, which is like, okay, can we make
our thing faster? Can we make it more
reliable? Or we can make it easier,
right? And can we guarantee around that?
And if the answer is yes, then it's
like, great. Well, then that's what
we're going to charge our premium and
bump prices by 20 to 40%, which sounds
like a lot, I know.
But we say, "Hey, if we don't meet any
of these qualifications, I'll give you
all my profit back." Which means that
you raise the price, and if for some
reason you don't meet it, you go back to
the exact same price you're charging
now, but everyone that you do meet
everything on, you get all the juice.
And if no one else does these kind of
guarantees, which basically no one does,
uh
then you can basically say, "Well, the
reason that they're not doing that is
because they're not confident they're
going to be on time and on budget."
Right? And I am. And so,
it's very easy for for somebody else to
say, "Hey, I'll do this job for you, and
maybe I'll be on time, and maybe I'll be
on budget." Uh but if I have no teeth in
that agreement, I'm going to promise
that it'll be free and I'll be done
tomorrow. But if I don't have to be
right about it, who cares? Sure, I'll be
done tomorrow. And they'll be like, "Oh,
I guess I get your point." Like, right.
I'll be done by this time and it'll be
done satisfactory at this price, period.
And you know that when you sign this,
you get that. That's it. And if for some
reason something happens, we'll come
back and fix it. Right? And so, by doing
that, um, you'll be able to increase the
cash flow, which will then allow you to
go recruit the extra tech that you need
so you can stay above the business and
then ultimately
honestly just keep advertising it so
that you can keep hiring and and
backfilling.
>> Okay. I can see that totally for my
service calls and stuff like that.
Kind of my bread and butter is I chase
six or seven different heating and
cooling companies around and do all
their electrical work.
>> Cool.
>> So, they take the lead. They
>> Yeah.
>> I have a flat rate sheet for that. But
the biggest thing they always complain
about is price. And we're super
efficient.
>> Yeah.
>> We get in, get out, but they're always
complaining about the cost that we came
in at.
>> Do they still buy from you?
>> Have for 6 years.
>> Yeah.
I mean,
I care more about what people do than
what they say.
>> Okay.
>> Everyone would like it cheaper.
>> Right.
>> I would like it cheaper.
I would like to all of you guys to get
paid less.
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Right?
But it's it's it
Yeah, I just I I pay very little
attention to that.
>> Okay.
>> Like, customers will always want it
cheaper, they will always want it
faster, they always want a guarantee.
Like, these are all thing like that will
not change.
>> So, when I'm moving my prices, don't
even
>> Yeah, be like, this is what it is.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Now, to to make yourself sleep
better, you have six or seven guys. It's
like, wouldn't it be cooler if you had
like 60?
>> Yeah.
>> Right? So, then we go back to the top
here, which is you have your way of
getting customers, which is mostly
chasing these six or seven heating and
cooling companies around. And so, it's
like, what do you get What do you do to
get the heating and cooling companies?
>> Basically, I've worked for one for 15
years and it's just constant.
>> Yeah.
>> And then, the other ones, since I opened
my business shortly after, they've been
with me. And so, really I have no
>> You have no function.
>> So, you should start doing This is what
I would do if I were you. I'd start
doing outreach to other heating and
cooling companies. Say, "Hey, let me
quote some of these jobs for you." Like
a a lot of people are just stuck with
the person they're they're with. They're
not happy, they're not unhappy, they're
just whatever. Like let me at least put
some It'll just keep them honest at
least.
Right? And so then you can just start
bringing business for yourself, and
that'll just give you more leverage with
all of the other kind of
negotiations that you have with the
existing companies.
>> Okay.
>> Cuz right now you're just dependent on
them. So, they have all the leverage.
>> Well, yeah. And then as soon as they
Like I'm missing out on work
>> Yeah.
>> because as soon as they say, "Hey, we
have a job tomorrow."
>> Yeah.
>> I'm going cuz they're my
>> They're my wells.
>> Right.
>> So, it's
>> So, you need more wells.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, so you need more wells, but to get
more wells, we have to tweak price to
get so that we can hire the manpower.
Like it's usually multi-step solutions.
Cuz like for most businesses, it's if it
were one thing, you probably would have
already seen it. So, it's usually second
order or third order that has to change
so we can reverse engineer back to the
fixing the core problem.
>> Got you.
Thank you.
>> That feel good though?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, cool. Good. Real quick, I'm going
to show you the exact 10-stage roadmap
from zero to 100 million plus
that less than 1% of companies finish
I've now done multiple times. And so I
can say with a lot of confidence that
these are the stages as head count
increases that you need to get through,
and I broke each of these down by eight
different functions of the business,
what the constraint feels like, like
what are the symptoms of it when you're
going through it, and then what steps we
actually took to graduate. And we've
done this across software, physical
products, uh service businesses, brick
and mortar, all of this, and it works.
And it's my gift to you. It's absolutely
free. And so the link's in the
description, but you just go
acquisition.com/roadmap.
Just enter your info, and it'll spit it
right back to you all free.
>> My name's Tanner Jared. We're at 1.5 mil
to date.
>> Amazing.
>> 700 net. My big concern is how do I make
the dream team like you have here? How
do I get technicians on board, sales
guys?
>> Yeah.
>> Like make it work.
>> So,
>> [sighs]
>> okay.
What breaks when we do more?
>> What breaks?
>> Like what stops you from doing this?
>> Uh
>> We're going to figure out which one like
order of ops. What stop What What What
breaks when you do that?
>> Biggest issue is technicians.
>> Okay, so techs is the is the issue.
Okay, so what do you So
What do you make on a tech?
>> Uh anywhere from 180 to 100
300,000 a year.
>> Per?
>> Yeah.
>> After cost?
>> Uh-huh.
>> Damn.
>> Well This year, yeah. Cuz we
>> is giving you a run for your money
there. I'm just saying, man.
All right.
All right, so we got 300k for the techs.
Got it.
Um all right, and you need them local in
Bozeman?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
Um and what are you doing right now to
recruit techs?
>> Uh
Honestly, kind of just gave up lately.
>> Yeah.
>> I would imagine that would make it
difficult to recruit more techs.
>> [laughter]
>> So, then then let me then let me ask the
next question, which is like what stops
you from recruiting more techs? Not the
decision. There's I've like
Some of you guys have probably seen that
management diamond that I have, which is
like people don't know that, you need to
do it, they don't know how to do it, um
they don't know when to do it by, they
have something blocking them, or there's
a motivation issue. I'm assuming you're
motivated. I'm assuming you already know
that you need to do it and how to do it.
>> 100%.
>> So, and you need to know the when is
now. So, I'm guessing there's something
blocking you.
>> My thing that's blocking me is
I have to be involved, I believe, in
every single
>> Strong words.
>> Yeah. Every single aspect of the
company.
>> Have to or choose to?
>> Choose to.
>> Okay. Just to work Just you know,
staying from saying I'm good. Okay.
>> And so I can't I can't let it go.
>> Okay. So, can't you won't?
>> We We have some Okay, we have some very
high-end clients, too.
>> Okay.
>> So, we we work at the Yellowstone Club
in Montana, Spanish Peaks. I know Matt
Damon, Jennifer Garner, Mark Zuckerberg.
>> you don't need to name drop.
>> Yeah, sorry.
>> [laughter]
>> But I I
>> You're a big deal.
>> I'm not a big deal. It's It's tiny.
>> Ed told me to say that.
>> [laughter]
>> Anyhow, and so it's it's hard to let
that go, you know, that
>> Yeah.
>> that ego.
>> So,
>> [laughter]
>> well, so fundamentally, this is so I
guess this is I mean, key man is the
number one risk of every business um for
two reasons. One, no one wants to buy
it, but second, you want to kill it
yourself at some point cuz you're like,
I don't want to do it. You should you
burn yourself in the car, right?
So, um
what we have to do is if we look at all
of the things like look at your
behaviors, not your feelings around
them, and say, "Okay, these are all the
things that I do on a daily basis.
Some of those things someone else can
do. Now, there's for sure things that
are higher leverage, higher value. It
might be that for you doing the design
for stuff is the highest leverage thing.
I don't know, it might be. It might It's
definitely not using your hands, I can
promise you that. Um it might be getting
the relationship and managing the
relationship. That might be the most
valuable thing. So, if we just did a if
we if we did a rank order, this is what
you'd have to do. It's like we do a time
study, which is step one.
So, take an Excel sheet, you can open up
on your phone. Every 15 minutes you have
an alarm. It'll annoy everyone, don't
worry about it. And every time it goes
off, you just write what you did in the
last 15 minutes.
And at the end of the week, you can look
at all those activities and rank them in
terms of revenue. Like which of these is
the most valuable and most unique?
And then when you look at the bottom
half of that list, does it neatly fit
into some person that either exists
currently that has bandwidth or somebody
that we can hire?
And
part of the the good news that you have
is that when you serve premium
customers, which you do, you can charge
a premium, which you do, which means
that you should have excess margins so
you can get premium people.
And so
right now, what will probably be
required is that you have to lower your
tolerance for mediocrity on your team.
And so it might cost So, if it's if
you're going to make $300,000 per year
for a tech, it's like would you be
willing to spend $50,000 to go get
another tech who's good?
>> 100%
>> Right. And so that's a combination of
like you could try the recruiting firm
thing, which is a thing. One that you
probably haven't thought of that I would
strongly recommend this probably be the
unlock for you is run national ads and
then offer a really generous relocation
package.
>> Mhm.
>> So make the 50 you're basically a
signing bonus. You get 25 now and 25 a
month six.
>> What do you think about instead of
having W-2 employees and how much they
cost running 1099 service techs?
>> You're a business.
Do they have to show up at certain times
and do work specific the way you want
them to do?
>> Yes.
>> They're employees.
>> Employees.
>> Yeah. Unless they're like
they're not vendors. They work for you.
If you have meetings and they have to
show up, they're they're employees. Um
so no, you you like
>> Keep it W-2.
>> Yeah, you want to go more legit, not
less legit.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Um
but fundamentally like if you were to
spend the $50,000 to go get another tech
we just have to like getting the tech I
don't think is going to be that hard,
honestly, if you're just willing to
spend the money for it, which you have
the money to do it.
Um and then the other piece is okay, now
that this person comes on, I have this
big stack of stuff. How can I give them
a third of it or half of it and then all
of a sudden you get those time back. And
so let me ask you a different question.
If you got half your time back could you
double the business?
>> 100%
>> Right. And so that's the game.
>> Yeah.
Beautiful. Thank you, Alex.
>> My name's Trenton. We sell roofing. Um
we're going to do about 3 million this
year. We'd like to be at 10 million. My
biggest constraint and what's stopping
me is that um for the last, you know,
eight years all of our lead gen has been
from
>> weather
>> from doors.
>> Okay.
>> So it's been 100% uh door-to-door lead
gen and now when we're trying to knock
for retail
it seems to be like like heavier of a
weight on the team.
>> What do you say retail? What do you
mean?
>> So uh like just people in market that
need a roof.
>> So like residential?
>> Residential.
>> Okay, got it. yeah.
>> And when you were doing door knocking
before you were knocking on
>> Residential doors.
>> Okay, so it was the weather guys.
>> getting funding from the insurance
company.
>> Got it. Word. Okay.
Okay, so
Keep going.
>> So now
um
with me being a door-to-door guy like
purchasing leads and all that was like
sacrilegious to me. So there's some
limiting beliefs there um that I started
to
you know, explore last October.
We bought leads
>> want to be lead curious. That's all I'm
asking for.
>> Yeah, I I am I'm very lead curious now.
>> [laughter]
>> And uh but I basically got slaughtered
learning this.
>> Yeah. This will be acquisitionary
binary. You know what I mean? Like be
non-binary with your leads. Like as many
as you want.
>> Yes, yes. No, that's what I'm trying to
do here. And when we did purchase leads
and I was able
>> version [laughter] by the way.
Yeah, go ahead.
>> And when we started to you know, stack
the guys' calendars, there was a big
culture shift.
>> Yeah.
>> Um where we actually saw like more
buy-in from the guys, but then like the
door knocking just poof
>> Yeah, cuz it was easier.
>> It was way easier.
>> Yeah.
>> But um like our CAC and all that was
absolutely horrid, right? So I was
spending like $7,500 just to acquire
one customer over the summer.
>> Okay.
>> And it wasn't sustainable. So I
>> make from a customer?
>> Um on average $6,500.
>> So that does not work.
>> No. It doesn't work.
>> Yeah.
>> And it was just like a lot of the
marketing agencies that we worked with
were like younger people. They were like
using AI tools, go high-level like
>> So we decided that we were going to
build it in-house.
>> Okay.
>> So with that being said, now it comes
into
you know, a leadership issue because I
need somebody that like knows how to you
know, market better than I do so that I
can focus on training and
>> Can I pause you real quick?
>> Yes, please.
>> Okay, cool. So you're at three, you want
to get to 10, you rebuilt it from storm
chasing to just straight-up door
knocking whenever. Fine. I think it was
a good idea. Um you had a door knocking
team, you took the same sales guys,
brought them on leads that you got them,
they got lazy, fat, and don't want to do
door knocking anymore.
>> Mhm.
>> So, great rule number one, outbound and
inbound are separate teams.
>> Yes.
>> Um inbound is what you graduate to.
And so, if you're an absolute savage,
like you just take children's souls and
just rip them out every day cuz you're a
terrible person.
Um but you're you're just unbelievable
at sales. Then and only then do you get
the opportunity for me to feed you
leads. Because these are the most
expensive leads that we have to work
very, very hard for to make sure and
like we cannot waste them on anybody who
cannot close everything.
And so, thank you. I hope that was an
amen.
Um and so
And so, so first off is the team should
be separate, but you're in this mix now.
You're in a little bit of a mess. And
so, my my two cents would be like, take
the cuz I'm sure their commissions have
gone down since they now are selling
nothing, basically.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. So, I would say, "Guys, my [__]
up. I went to this thing. He told me I
did this big boo-boo, which is inbound
and outbound were together, which is not
how it should be.
Everybody get back on the streets. You
guys do that. And then for the absolute
savages of you, because you can usually
have far fewer people on inbound,
that becomes the Christmas tree of the
career path.
Because on inbound, I can feed you and
you can do like five sales a day. You
can't do that door knocking. Right? But
I you can do it if I'm feeding you leads
that are already qualified, already set,
already gone through a VSL, whatever,
um in the sales motion.
And then those guys can absolutely clean
up. But you get you earn the opportunity
to get that level of commissions. Now,
the commission structure should also be
different on inbound because you have to
pay for those leads. So, it's a
different role. They graduate to it.
It's more volume, lower per, but it's
more reliable, which guys with families,
things like that, if you have a bad day,
you close two, and a good day, you close
seven. It's different than you have a
bad day, you can close zero, zero, zero.
Right? It's much more uh it's much more
stressful. And so, guys will be happy to
even give up they'll even make the same
money, but should have it be more
reliable. They'll be and you don't have
to be in the sun.
So.
>> So then we should hire for inbound
sales.
>> Yeah, or take one of the guys you have
who's really good at it.
And put everybody else back on the
street so that you just funnel
everything to that guy who cuz then you
can iterate faster cuz you're new on
this. And so you want to you never want
to have too many news cuz kind of like
the brick analogy I gave at the
beginning, the more news there are, the
more likely something's going to [__]
up, right? And so it's like I know this
is a absolute savage salesperson. If
they're closable, he'll close them or
she'll close them. And so then the only
variable we have is just what offer lead
source am I getting and like what
process are going from lead to talking
to them. Those are the only variables
you have to play with and so you can
control it's much easier to iterate on
that and then get it to go faster.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay.
Okay. And then okay. So then I want to
hire a marketing director or leader
um to manage that.
>> Outbound team goes out, inbound team
becomes the one guy. You need to hire a
marketer person who actually knows what
they're doing. Probably pay more than
you expect, but then that person will be
worth it. Your entire business is sales
and marketing so you should have the
core elements of the business in house.
>> Okay.
>> Great. If you need help with the sales
process, we can help.
>> Excellent. Thank you.
>> My name is Art. We sell junk removal and
demolition to commercial property
managers. Currently do 1 million a year.
Would love to be at 10 million a year.
What's currently stopping us is knowing
which sales
channel to focus on. I know it's
important that we pick one, capitalize
on it. And I'm wondering how much time,
energy, or volume do I spend on one
while I determine if that's going to be
our channel or not and know whether to
leave that one or focus on that one.
>> Yeah. So I'll give you two answers to
that question. So before I answer it,
I'm going to do the first thing though.
Really the second thing first.
Um so why What do you do currently right
now to get customers?
>> Uh right now it's been mostly referrals.
>> Okay. So you can't do more referrals
because there's nothing for you to do
besides do a good job. Okay. That's
fine. Um if referrals is the way you're
getting business, what ways have you
begun or you haven't started doing sales
channels yet?
>> Uh so I uh we've started to lay the
framework for doing uh email uh cold
outreach as well uh simultaneously with
LinkedIn outreach and then also uh
converting some of our social media
efforts into a bit of outreach as well
with people who are engaging.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh so there's some of the things that
we're
>> Like ManyChat and then DM and the whole
lot.
>> Yeah, yeah. I'm more more manual for now
while we get the uh uh flow going and
then also um I'm in a networking BNI so
that's
>> Yeah. I would prefer you stick with one
of them
and just do more in that thing.
And so if the question is how do I So
the original question was how do I know
which one to pick and how long to stick
with it?
So I think I will reject the premise,
which is that one of them is going to
work. Like you will make one of them
work.
And so you could make any of them work.
And so I would take the hypothetical
extreme of
is there a business that acquires other
businesses' customers
in each of those different channels in
your market?
>> Uh I'm I'm not sure.
>> I'll bet there is.
Uh there probably are some junk removal
people who do it via social media and
they take it that way. Some people
probably do it via LinkedIn. Some people
do uh cold outreach. All three of those
are
super repeatable channels that anyone
could run.
So all of them can work. My
recommendation to you would be the one
that you have the highest overlap with
existing skill set.
>> Mhm.
>> Between you and team.
So if you and or your team have more
knowledge around social media stuff, I'd
be like just double down on social
media. If it's I have uh you know, we're
better at kind of the outbound motion,
then I would say go do the outbound
motion
via via email. If it's like, well, we
want to both these things, it's like,
well, why don't we just send more
emails?
You know what I mean?
>> Got it.
>> Does that help?
>> Yeah, it does.
>> Okay, good.
That was super That was like, you sure?
Everything else you get I got That was
That was a That was an easy one. That
was like a warm-up.
>> [laughter]
>> Well, for um I guess follow-up
since you're taking more questions.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh I guess if you had to just say one,
like let's irrelevant to what the team
has
>> Which one do you have the best skill set
uh in?
>> To be honest, I just don't have the
skill set in I guess networking is
number one. Like in when I'm in person
with people, I'm doing the best.
>> Okay.
So So, hear me out then.
Wild idea. So, you do networking stuff.
And so, if I said, "I want you to spend
4 hours a day to find every local
community-based related event with 20
people or less or 50 people or less in
it that have people who are similar to
your avatar. Would you be able to do
that?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, why can't we do more of that?
>> We can do more of that.
>> Okay. So, how many of those events do
you currently go to? And I'm guessing
you get customers from when you go
there, right?
>> Uh yeah, they they compound over time.
Uh we go to uh currently a few a week
and then we're meeting one-on-one with a
lot of people we meet.
>> Afterwards, right. So, I would say, "All
right, well then what would it take for
us to go to like several a day?"
That would be my first kind of like
risk-adjusted move
because the other things you haven't
done yet at all. So, it's like, "How do
I go from one to three just like this
year?"
I would do that.
Cuz then it'll free up more cash flow
because the the issue that you have
right now, especially like in the in the
in the swamp that you're in right now, I
would just do way more of the thing
you're currently doing
um as my path of at least getting to one
to three. It's probably super profitable
for you as well. Um and then I would
invest
more of those resources into
um learning one of the other channels.
>> Got it.
Perfect. Thank you.
>> Cool. You bet.
>> My name's Adrian. I own a commercial
construction company. Did 11 million uh
this year, 10 last year. Um
read the book uh Built to Sell. So, I
started analyzing my company and I said
or I figured out that uh construction
companies are not an easy asset to sell.
Um that their enterprise value is based
off of assets or backlog of work.
>> Uh-huh.
>> As a commercial contractor, I thought to
myself, "Okay, well, how am I going to
do that?" So, we started doing public
works projects, bought some heavy
equipment. Now, we have contracts that
are for several years.
At the same time, with the clientele
base that I had uh in the multifamily
space, I started thinking about, "Okay,
well, if I don't want to sell this
company, if it's going to be that
difficult, how do I get recurring
revenue?" So, I started an elevator
company.
And uh
>> Okay.
>> over the last 12 months, we did 3
million
>> Yeah.
>> to start. And um
>> It's a racket. Congrats.
>> [laughter]
>> I have elevators. It's ridiculous.
>> We can help you.
So, uh if you were me, you know, with
the two companies and the combined
revenue,
>> Um
>> what would you do next in order to go
from 10 to 100?
>> What's profit on three versus 11?
>> 30% on the three,
>> Mhm.
>> 18% on the 11.
>> Okay. So, you're making roughly double
on the construction side, but cash flow
sucks and it's a pain and you never take
the money out of the business, probably.
I'm guessing. Um
okay. So, it's a tough call cuz you
already did it, right? You can't like
not have the kid. It's already out there
running around. Um
>> That's what I had said.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, you can't can't insert. It doesn't
doesn't go back up, right? Um
okay. So,
I think it again, it depends on what you
want to do. So, I think the elevator
company totally could sell.
Um if you wanted to sell that business,
um
>> I do.
>> Are you splitting your time right now?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. So, it might take
$800,000 in profit on the construction
side to get the two or three leaders
that you need to do it without you, and
then it would continue to exist.
Um I do think the elevator is the better
opportunity for the reasons that you
already are aware of, and it probably
grew significantly faster than the other
one did.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah. Um
this isn't normally what I would say in
this type of situation, but I'm just
familiar with it. Um, what timeline do
you have? Like sell in five, sell in 10?
>> Definitely 10. Um, you know, if I could
do it in five.
>> Okay. [snorts] You could sell in five. I
mean, what's the growth rate on the
elevator?
>> Well, I mean, year one, 3 million.
>> Oh, year one, right, right. So, it's a
straight up elevator. Okay, sorry. Uh
>> [laughter]
>> Exactly.
>> Straight to the penthouse. Um
Okay. Uh I like
So, there's the reasonable advice, which
is, "Hey, hire the people and then let
them continue to run that thing." And
then I would say like what the quote
Alex advice would be,
which is super unreasonable. Um And I
only give it because this is what I did.
Um I burn things down.
And so, if I can't exit it, so like you
could exit the 11 now for way less than
you think it's worth, right?
I'd be I would just be willing to exit
it. I had six gyms and I fire sold them
in 90 days.
I made I made in total on six what I
should have made on one.
And then within six months I was doing a
million a month on the next thing. And
so, once it was like
clear that this was a way better
opportunity, like the orders of
magnitude better, which I think you were
in that situation right now. It's super
niched. It's you've obviously got ins in
terms of understanding how to work. It's
already recurring. It is a racket. Uh
a legal racket, but
>> [laughter]
>> it is. Oh, it is. Um
if you're willing to take a step back to
like you will if you had if you're like,
"I want to do this in two years." You'll
like the break-even point on this is two
years.
Which is like if you got rid of the
construction firm in the next 90 days
and you said, "I don't care what the
price is. I just want all the headache
back."
You will grow so much faster on the
elevator side. Like it'll Like you did
three while splitting your attention.
If you had had full attention, you might
be at eight.
And so, I tend to think only exclusively
on opportunity cost. Um I don't normally
give that advice cuz it's like it's just
so hard for people to do, but I burn
things down. When I like am very clear
that this is the next thing I'm going to
do, just cuz I know that my
the opportunity cost of the time of just
continuing to wind this down or get it
ready for sale, I could make more than
I'm going to make on that sale in this
opportunity.
So, like
let's say that a perfect a perfect exit
for that business would be like $5
million or something, right? Based on
the assets and the AR that you have
coming. It's like for me to build
another million dollars in recurring
revenue in the elevator business, I can
do that in a quarter, which equals the
enterprise value of the other thing.
And so, as long as you can get out of
your head around like cuz everyone if
you do this,
everyone will tell you that you're
crazy.
Um everyone has told me that I was crazy
every time I've done this. Um and that's
why also none of them are wealthier than
I am. You know, just like like no one
who is wealthier than me told me that.
So, as long as you're good with it and
you can just stomach the fact that your
wife's like, "You worked so hard on
this." and your dad's like, "This is
ridiculous. You all the blood, sweat,
and tears and all this stuff." and
you're like,
"I did this so I could learn all these
skills and apply it here. It was not a
waste cuz I was the asset."
>> Thank you.